no I'm Alex gladder i work at Princeton  University I am trained as a physicist  but I do arms control and examine for a  living I I support the ban treaty  movement I think there has not been much  progress in nuclear arms control and  disarmament the NPT the news no  non-proliferation treaty is important  but it hasn't really delivered was I  think international community expects I  believe now is the time to have to move  the agenda forward and and and really  you know make progress toward the  government I work with students I teach  student who were born in nineteen ninety  they have not seen much progress since  then since the end of the Cold War they  don't really understand what in others  mean by a step-by-step approach when  since the mid-1990s we haven't really  seen much if anything so I think the  band movement is kind of very important  and kind of changing this as it's making  a difference in this stalemate  you